>> Jesse: WITH SPECIAL COUNSELS
RUSSIA'S PROBE WILL RETURN NEXT
MOUNTING SCRUTINY AND FOR
UNEXPECTED REASONS.
FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE WENDT
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS FOR THE
RUSSIA PROBE.
IT'S BEHIND THE HILLARY CLINTON
E-MAIL SCANDAL THAT IS COMING
INTO SHARP FOCUS.
MACK YATES JOINS US FROM FLOOR
AND HIS MEETING WITH McCABE
YESTERDAY.
WELCOME, CONGRESSMAN.
WHAT HAPPENED BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS AND WHAT ARE YOU ALLOWED
TO SAY?
>> THIS IS THE FIRST OF A SERIES
OF CONFIDENTIAL WITNESSES WITH
KEY TESTIMONY.
I CAN'T SHARE WITH YOU THE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS OR ANSES.
I CAN SHARE WITH YOU MY
REACTIONS TO THEM.
FIRST, HILLARY CLINTON
ABSOLUTELY GOT SPECIAL
TREATMENT.
HER PROCESS DEPARTED FROM THE
STANDARD PROCESS MOST AMERICANS
WOULD FACE.
SHE RECEIVED THE SPECIAL
TREATMENT BECAUSE SHE WAS A
CANDIDATE FOR PRESIDENT.
NO OTHER REASON.
THIRD THING.
THERE WERE PEOPLE IN THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE
HILLARY CLINTON DIDN'T FACE
CONSEQUENCES.
PROBE AND PERSECUTING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WITHOUT A VALID BASIS.
THAT'S WHY THE WORK WE'RE DOING
IS SO IMPORTANT.
>> Jesse: VERY INTERESTING.
SO WE KNOW THAT HILLARY GOT
SPECIAL TREATMENT FROM THE
WAS EXONERATED.
AT THIS POINT WHAT ARE YOU GOING
WE HAVE TO FIND OUT WHETHER OR
DISRUPTING THE POLICIES AND
PRIORITIES OF THE UNITED STATES
ON AN ON GOING BASIS.
UNTIL WE HAVE A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION OF THE BRIBES THAT
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION TOOK AND
THE ACTIONS THAT FELL AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF THOSE BRIBES, I
FEAR WE WON'T TRULY KNOW THE
DEPTH OF THE CORRUPTION AND THE
LAST ADMINISTRATION.
WE'VE GOT THE CHANGE THE LAW SO
THAT NEVER AGAIN CAN WE HAVE A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE SOMEONE GETS
BECAUSE THEY'RE A CANDIDATE FOR
HIGH OFFICE.
THAT IS NOT THE BLIND LADY
JUSTICE THAT WE PROMISED THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY
UNDER OUR CONTUSION, JESSE.
SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
INVESTIGATE HILLARY AND THE
FOUNDATION?
>> FOR FIVE MONTHS NOW, OVER 20
MEMBERS OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE HAVE BEEN CALLING FOR
A SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL TO
INVESTIGATE THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION, THE E-MAIL SERVER
AND THE HANDLING OF THAT
PROCESS.
SITTING ON HIS HANDS DESPITE THE
FACT THAT WE'VE HAD THESE CALLS
FOR A SECOND SPECIAL COUNSEL.
IT'S A DOUBLE STANDARD WHEN YOU
HAVE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL THAT
HAS A LIMIT BUDGET, LIMITLESS
AUTHORITY PERSECUTING THE
PRESIDENT AND NOT LOOKING AT THE
CRIMES FROM THE REAL CRIMINALS.
>> Jesse: SO CAN I ASK YOU?
I KNOW YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO SAY
EVERYTHING.
DID YOU ASK McCABE ABOUT THAT
MEETING WHERE IT WAS THE FBI
AND TAKING OUT AN INSURANCE
POLICY IF TRUMP WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT?
DID YOU ASK ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, I CAN'T GO INTO THE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ASKED AND THE
ANSWERS PROVIDED.
I WILL SAY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
COMMENTARY FROM THE MAINSTREAM
EXPLAIN IT.
>> I'M GOING TO ASSUME THAT YOU
ASKED ABOUT THAT.
BECAUSE THAT IS HUGE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW ABOUT
IT.
IT LOOKS LIKE JAMES BAKER, WHO
WAS THE TOP LAWYER IN THE FBI,
CONTACT WITH THIS LEFT WING
OUTFIT MOTHER JONES AND DAVID
KORN.
TWO WEEKS LATER, THEY BREAK THE
DOSSIER STORY.
SEEMS REALLY SUSPICIOUS.
>> YEAH, I DON'T THINK JAMES
BAKER IS A LAWYER IN THIS FACT
PATTERN ANYMORE.
I BELIEVE MR. BAKER IS A
WITNESS.
BECAUSE HE'S A WITNESS, I THINK
HE'S VERY WELL MAY BE ONE OF THE
NEXT PEOPLE CALLED BEFORE ONE OF
THESE COMMITTEES CONDUCTING A
FACT-BASED INVESTIGATION.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE A
NUMBER OF CONTAMINATING EVENTS
THAT ERODE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE'S
>> Jesse: SEEMED LIKE THE MORE
PEOPLE INVESTIGATE, THE